so hopefully by now you are most the way
or are done drawing a normal
distribution curve we're gonna use this
to answer this question let's have a
read of it together
it says mm-hmm experience has shown that
the scores of a commonly used IQ test
can be assumed to be normally
distributed like so okay with a mean of
100 standard deviation of 15 okay stop
right there if we know those two facts I
can immediately go to my normal
distribution and start to fill in
information for example the most
important place on your normal
distribution is the place that
everything centers around this guy right
in the middle which is what it's the
mean in this case that is a hundred now
remember the the thing about the normal
distribution is the mean and the median
and the mode they're all the same thing
they're all the equal value okay so then
100 in there okay now if you feed back
to some of the diagrams you gave you
guys earlier this week about the normal
distribution you can see I've got these
markings do you notice that I've got
exactly three going this way and three
going that way each one represents going
out one standard deviation from mean
then another standard deviation then
another standard deviation okay now I
actually know what the standard
deviation is it's 15
okay so let's um let's do the left-hand
side first if I go one standard
deviation below what should be the next
number down 85 I'll go again the next
one down take my 15 again 70 and if I
subtract one more time you get to 55
right I can do subtraction my brain work
good okay what about the other direction
these are even easier we're just adding
15 every time so 1:15 1:30 1:45 okay now
what you can see is and I didn't ask you
this before but maybe you looked and
thought well what's that about you might
notice I have another horizontal axis
underneath what we've written here these
are the IQ scores so these are X's right
what I'd like underneath here is the
corresponding z-scores
so if I call this guy this parallel line
z axis right on the mean you've got a
z-score
of zero right you're not above or below
the mean
that's what a Zedd score is zero
actually means right not quiet not quiet
I mean you can interpret it that way but
I'm not I'm not getting to that yet
think about as I went down here I was
subtracting a standard deviation every
time right so I would have gone negative
one then negative two then negative
three we tend to stop there right same
thing going in the opposite direction
one two and three so here are the
z-scores here are the actual scores well
you can call them raw scores if you like
okay all right so now we can then take
this and use it to help us answer the
questions it says approximately because
this is just a model right but it's a
very good model approximately what
percentage of the distribution lies
between 85 and 115 so let's have a look
at where that is on our normal
distribution very good now some of you
have like your previous pages of working
there have a look this is the area that
I'm interested in here right in the
middle right now wonder how many of you
recall and this is literally the way I
would write it by the way I'm gonna rule
a line here for Part A a score between
what do we say 85 and 115 okay good it's
corresponds to a z-score between
negative one and one do you agree with
that and if we go back to how we define
the normal distribution we would say
therefore this is 68 percent of the
population 68 percent lies within this
range is that okay so far so good
how about Part B have a look at the
numbers okay good so when you have a
look you're like 55 it's all the way
down here three standard deviations
below and three standard deviations
above so the way I'd write this is if
you're X that's your actual score your
raw score if it's between these values
then the corresponding Z scores from
negative 3 to 3
are you with me
so that's 99.7% question yes I actually
can't answer that question off the top
of my head I just google that to be
honest if you look up mathematics HSC
2020 reference sheet you'll find it I'll
be the first thing say yeah
this one or this one or both yep shop
okay so where do I get this number from
sorry yeah yeah where do I get this
number from where I got it from was
piling the definition of the normal
distribution okay we can say 68% of
scores will be one standard deviation
away 95% of scores will be 2 and then
99.7 will be within three standard
deviations of the mean and unfortunately
there's not much of a oh this is why is
99.7 the reason for that number
specifically is kind of weird and we'll
get to it later but for now it just to
remember this one yeah there you go it
sits on the shape okay
oh it's 1:00 1:30 1:45 very sorry my
mother add there we go Sibella okay
Patsy's the trickiest one here is where
if you have some other colors they will
really help and if you have a decent
sized normal distribution that will also
really help look at the question it says
what's the percentage of the population
that's above 130 X is above 130 that's
the question okay question yeah
are you talking about the - in the
middle of Isaiah
I I write the - in the middle of the Z
because if I do not it so quickly turns
into a - especially when I'm in a hurry
in an exam where I don't read carefully
so this is kind of a habit that I pick
up on okay do you have to do it no but I
strongly recommend it have a look
where's 130 on our graph here it is 130
all right here's a hundred thirty but
what I want this is different right what
I want is from here to the right does
that make sense 130 and above now this
is very different from a and B a and B a
kind of straight out of the textbook
they're like within this range and then
when this strange that's why these
numbers are literally the ones we just
handed to you okay but you actually have
to think to do Part C which is what I'm
going to help you do yeah I guess so if
I started at 130 I'm not saying there's
any end point but I might as well just
write it like I don't like writing
infinity it's a weird idea I'm just
gonna say X is greater than or equal to
okay so how I do this alright well have
a look closely with me I said some
colors would be really helpful here
right do you remember we did Part A we
said that this whole section in here was
34% do you agree sorry 68% so therefore
if I just take this half here right
68% this is half of that so this is the
34% that I are mistaking centers now
okay that's 34% now have a look at the
next section over and you really need to
think about this how big is this section
how big is that hmm
now remember right if I went with ya
think about it look at it with me you're
12 if I went all the way out to my two
standard deviations here to here how
much is that it's 95 right well no
that's 95 if I subtract this 68 in the
middle if I subtract the 68 in the
middle that'll leave me with these two
green sections right well I haven't
called this green sacked you don't want
it I just want one of them right
what's 95 take away the 68 that's 27 95
percent take away 68 percent that gives
me the 27 but I don't want two of them I
just want one that makes sense so that's
why I divide by two that gives me 13.5
percent okay now this this is what I
need despite looking very indirect this
is what I need to work out the answer
this question because can you like do
you agree with me right underneath this
probability density function that's what
this thing is the whole thing adds up to
100% do you agree the whole guess all
point of it right so if I go from the
middle all the way to the right and
never stop what's that attitude it's
half right it's 50% well the part that
I'm interested in is the part of that
50% that's not this and it's not that
it's this guy in here do you agree so to
work out this answer I need to do 50%
that's the whole right-hand side and
then subtract these two numbers are you
with me that's 34 and 13 and a half what
do you get 2.5 2.5 now as a final note
right we could have done it one other
way which is we could have worked out
instead of doing this subtraction thing
you could do the same thing to work out
this guy you can work that out in
exactly the same way and you can also
work out this guy over here I'm gonna
tell you right now if you go ahead and
give that a go you'll get two point
three five percent
and not point one five percent guess
what happens when you add those up you
get the same two and a half you say that
we got before that make sense okay